cain commentaires d'andré france a rien
de tout cela ne nous sera étrangers
d'ici un instant bravo est en route pour
porto rico comme on dit dans les rues
porto rico où nous allons en bateau et
même comme vous le voyez à la nage
on vous dira que c'est l'espagne pour
ajouter aussitôt que porto rico ce
l'amérique du nord celle des gratte-ciel
des gadgets et du mouvement perpétuel
en fait c'est l'une de ses îles caraïbes
où les civilisations bien élevé accepte
par dérogation à l'ordre habituel des
successions historique
deux voisines essence détruire
et de faire bon ménage pour peu que
l'une d'elles bien sûr consent à faire
le ménage
chacune d'elles débarque avec son
matériel sa manière d'être et ses idées
l'espagnol avec ses églises et son point
d'honneur l'américain avec ses
mécaniques et son goût de la réussite et
ça réussit porto rico
devient la plus riche c'est à dire la
moins pour des antilles avec chiffres
ont un revenu moyen très moyen de 350 $
par habitant des hôtels chargés toute
l'année de touristes et d'entrepreneurs
américains venus traiter leurs affaires
ou leur surmenage des entreprises des
commerces des taxis des avions des
hélicoptères et bien entendu des
pétroliers comme celui que vous venez de
voir qui a échoué au port il y a 6 mois
et auxquelles on a eu l'excellente idée
de ne pas toucher chacun sait en effet
depuis le naufrage du torrey canyon que
les pétroliers sont des espèces de ces
chevaux lumineuse qui ne meurent pas
sans vider leur énorme poche d'encre
noire
pour être complet n'oublions pas de
mentionner la côte et plus exactement au
dessous des hôtels futuriste
l'agrémenter de piscines et de terrasses
fleuris où l'on peut détailler
quelques-unes des mille cinq cents
variétés d'orchidées qui viennent this
it comme le blé bien en beauce
un nombre considérable de kenya sans
aucune trace de confort moderne que
l'américain est peut-être tenté
d'attribuer à la nonchalance espagnol et
l'espagnol à l'expansion américaine qui
va comme un express à prendre en marche
tout le monde n'a pas le coup d'oeil et
le poignet voulu
cela dit on ne sait pas très bien
toulonnais et son andalousie pourrait en
californie j'ai bien pris à washington
le capitole bien blanc construit au
milieu de la ville porterez talent que
moi dans une république sans doute
encore que le steak de porto rico ne
soient pas les plus plaire lille ditto
est autonome dans le cadre de l'union
fédérale ce qui rappelle certains statut
d'indépendance dans l'interdépendance
qui s'interprète d'ailleurs tout
autrement qui les portoricains sont
considéré aux états unis comme des
citoyens américains à part entière
toutefois ils n'ont pas de représentants
au congrès à quoi le combat estia prête
à répondre qu'il n'a pas non plus de
représentants au capitole de san juan
qui choisit
ces fonctionnaires et son goût et on
arrête on est en amérique sans diète
peut-être après tout et on à monaco
puisque lille a ceci de commun avec la
principauté
outre le charme et les fleurs les jeunes
n'ont mené que l'on y peut jouer à tous
les jeux de hasard ou la garantie du
gouvernement et que l'on n'y paient pas
d'impôts et moins de sernhac qui ne sont
pas les plus touchants
oui
tout cela à l'ombre puissante et désolé
du fort del moro qui va me rappeler à
coups de boules est d'époque que je ne
vous ai rien dit de la guerre
hispano-américaine de la fin du siècle
dernier et dont porto rico a été l'un
des enjeux meba personne apparemment n'y
pense plus ici ni ailleurs
tout cela donc avec le vieux fort qui ne
défend plus rien depuis qu'il y a
quelque chose à défendre
sous un ciel gris qui retient son nom
mais non pas son soleil nous fait une
île composite riches
épaules trop riche
être au port agricole et industriel qui
a trouvé le 21e siècle
à la sortie du 16e
qui pense en espagnol en parlant en mai
une île ravissante la plus belle
peut-être
les antilles
heureuse selon l'heure et le lieu
un paradis prospère et nécessiteux
ou personnes dans les rues andalouse qui
se jette dans les blocs américains ne
parlent tout à fait la même langue et où
cependant tout le monde se comprend
ok a big boss
il
ça